non-minimalists
how did you navigate moving in together
when it came to both of your guys's
items i pretty much just wrote a list of
what mariah could and couldn't keep
there was only one
um actually it wasn't really
it was super easy and simple um
i had a lot of stuff as i said earlier
maybe that wasn't on this podcast but um
when we first met i was interested in
the minimalism thing just because i
hadn't really heard anything about it so
i asked him about it and he sent me a
video
which i ended up watching all of because
um
as i was watching i was picking up the
piles and piles of clothing all around
my room
and it just made a lot of sense that if
i didn't have all this stuff i would
probably
be freer be
less tied down in a way and um so they
were actually on tour they're on their
100 city tour when we moved in
and so for the first
few months before we moved in i had
started just
looking through my stuff and deciding
what i wanted to keep and not and
realizing that i had things like two
vcrs and no tv and i was like okay maybe
i should uh reevaluate the things that
i'm holding on to
and so i probably got rid of
i'd say eighty percent of my stuff
before we moved in together did he ever
try to convince you to get rid of
anything
no the only thing that he did say was
that he would prefer if i got rid of my
um
furniture like i had this couch set um
that got a really good deal on so it was
super ugly but it was like
comfortable and super cheap um i didn't
say she had to do anything no he did not
he said his preference was that i not
bring
couches don't have those couches in
can
those
there yeah and so um
i had no attachment to them like i said
i just got them because um they were
there was a defect or something so i got
them super it was a good idea they were
comfy they were super comfortable
but we kind of wanted to make it you
know our place and so
yeah it was super easy i just brought my
cat and
maybe 50 pairs of shoes mm-hmm oh that's
right
how many shoes do you think you have now
like 10.
wow
and and all of that from no convincing
what's fascinating we talked about the
earlier in the episode we talked about
the denver event that we had and this
woman comes up and tries to get us to
convince her husband who's in the
audience to get rid of some of his stuff
and it's like well ryan didn't even
convince his wife who had a ton of stuff
when they first met there was no
convincing there because the best way to
convince someone is not to convince them
at all
it's to show them the benefits through
not not here's a list of the benefits
mariah if you got rid of your shoes
you're going to be uh recording this
data here you're 87 percent happier with
fewer shoes it doesn't work that way
right yeah
and so
it was never about trying to persuade
you
it was
helping you understand some of the
benefits for you which are different
from ryan now i tell you bex and i have
one other thing that really helps us and
i don't know jessica if this would help
you at all but we don't bring anything
new into the house unless we've both
agreed on it same yeah yeah and what's
really helpful about that is sometimes
it can be a little frustrating because
oh i want to bring this one thing in or
she wants to bring this one thing in
usually she wants to bring this one
thing in and uh and she meaning ella our
daughter um
and we just have to agree on it together
and it's not to deprive ourselves but
it's to be more thoughtful
about the things that we accumulate
because ultimately most of the things
i've ever brought into my life
i have a little bit of regret forever
buying them
yeah i'm telling you man like
you have to go out of your way you have
to look for reasons
to
um support
your partner's
preferences
if you do that
like not only does it kind of
it becomes a joy to like support your
partner's preferences but also
then your partner in turn
will start to support your preferences
yeah and if they don't well then that's
a totally different conversation red
flag yeah and and the thing is is like a
lot of people like
you know that wife uh that that woman
the wife of the man with the stuff in
the garage how do i convince my husband
it's like well
how have you gone out of your way to
support what his preferences are right
now you're just laying a preference down
but like how have you gone out of your
way and then we were able to help her
see like if you actually think about it
like
he's going out of his way to do what he
can
you know with uh her a couple things
she's like well he tried to do this and
he tried to do that
and i was like well wait a minute like
he's going out of his way
to support your preference he's trying
to do what he can so what are you doing
that you can do yes to help support his
preferences but like that is
i mean i and i feel like that not just
with you know mariah my romantic partner
but
any partner man any any friendship
family relationship i mean any other
person yeah exactly now
making of demands was what she was doing
in denver it doesn't work and i think if
ryan would have came to you and said hey
mariah you have 130 pairs of shoes i
demand you get rid of 120 pairs of shoes
let's say you even complied with his
demand
you wouldn't feel as good about the
relationship right now as you do even
though it's the same exact outcome yeah
now part of that is because that
wouldn't be compassionate on his part it
would have been unloving on his part to
demand that from you yeah true i think
it helped that i grew up in a household
where
most of the arguments were
around how much stuff was in the house
my dad wanted there to be not so much
stuff and my mom wanted to hold on to
everything and so i think growing up in
this
turmoil of how much stuff is appropriate
for a household
um when
he brought up minimalism and i was
watching actually there was a talk that
you guys did it was just like a question
and answer um the seattle talk okay and
uh
it just like clicked with me like
wow like this could be
just my mind went blank um
a better way to start a relationship is
on the same page about stuff as opposed
to
um
not
caring or even being aware of the
another person's preference and then
trying to
push your preference onto them
later yes oh yeah you saw the tension
that created in your household growing
up
and you didn't want to replicate that
tension in your relationship because you
knew that was not desirable any sort of
tension like that is going to lead to
some discontent within you
and so
the best way to avoid that is to not
bring it in in the first place right
yeah
your dad was like so into the before i
even i think before i even went to your
parents house
he was very into the minimalism thing
and uh yeah and now i understand why
why he was so excited about it he's like
oh
yeah man you need to talk to my wife
but get in it yeah and yeah and your
mom's awesome your mom is so awesome
now uh before we get to our last
question when you met ryan
he uh he looked different than what he
looks now
um he was he was closer to corporate
ryan even though he was
he was growing his hair out at the time
i remember this yeah he was a little
shorter yeah i used to straighten my
hair did he still have his beard at the
time um he did but the when we actually
met our first date it was after a
halloween party
um we both went to halloween different
halloween parties the night before and
he had actually shaved off of his shaved
off his beard that was garth or no i was
wayne from wayne's world
clean shaven because he's clean-shaven
yeah oh wow and i was a little
disappointed
yeah i thought you were luigi that year
no that was that wasn't that was a
peaburg
which i don't even know that was the
lamest costume but anyway
[Laughter]
um
she one of the things she has said to me
she's like you know i really liked
you know the profile picture i had up
she was like you had the perfect amount
of scruff
so yeah so like i tried to keep it like
this but then you know and
guys will understand this you're like
i'll shave tomorrow i shave my legs
every day oh [ __ ] right exactly right
women
women are on it i mean i shave my legs
every day too but it's the beard
[Laughter]
you know um even if you grew your hair
out on your leg that's the oh it's for
me not for you oh okay
but yeah i mean just with so i try to
keep it like this length because i know
that's that's her preference but that is
one thing where i'm just like i'll put
it off to tomorrow but and then and then
i get compliments when i start to grow
it out right people will be like man i'm
really liking the beard
i'm like yeah well my wife does not
well it's funny because we've gone
through these stages i remember we first
started the minimalist ryan and i were
in the corporate world it's been 11
years now
and you know so ryan was still very
corporate ryan he had the shortcut hair
and he was clean-shaven or he'd have a
five o'clock shadow and and that was
sort of one iteration and then we we
started to move to montana and he grew
his hair out a little bit and then he
grew this big beard remember the the
2013 pictures with me you and colin
you had a big old beard i just wanted to
see how thick i could like grow the
beard out and how full it would and it
turns out like
it's just not a very full beard i think
if you google image search ryan you'll
find the different iterations of ryan
nicodemus for sure and now you've sort
of
around 2014 2015 is when this aesthetic
developed and it you've it's like oh i
feel like i found me in a way and i've
sensed that about you yeah and now the
new you is gonna be a mullet
dude i'm so tempted i
uh
wrote to oya oya is the the gal who cuts
my hair and mariah's hair for that
matter she's an awesome lady we've
talked about it on the podcast before
but i was like
uh will you cut can you do a mullet for
me like if i want you to do that she's
like look
she's like remember in the wedding
crashes where they're arguing over
uh there's like a kid talking to a
balloon maker yeah he's like this kid
wants a dog and the guy's like do you
really want a dog i mean i'll do a dog
for you but i but but i don't want to
make you a dog out of this balloon and
the kid's like i want a dog i want to
know he's like fine you got every
freaking dog
she was like that's how i would feel
with this like i'll do it for you she's
like but i don't think you should do it
or no she was like i don't want to do it
it's what it was she's like but i'll do
it for you so uh anyway
tbd comment on this episode if i should
get a mullet or not yeah let us know
patrons yeah did you enjoy this video if
so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free